well as you guys know it's the 25th
anniversary of happy gilmore
i'm good for happy gilmo my god so what
we thought we'd do we put together a
little table read for you guys we have
shooter played by phil mickelson happy
gilmore played by bryson di [ __ ]
tom brady will uh be the role of the
narrator
and aaron rodgers maybe his most
important role to date
he'll be virginia narrator please
action he's got similar hairs virginia
right now
scene golf club house bar
happy gilmore approaches the bar shooter
mcgavin notices happy
shooter turns toward the bar and walks
up to happy that was quite a show you
put on there today gilmore you were the
talk of the tournament
wow thanks a lot well you really crushed
that ball off the tee
i'll tell you what you know you'd be
something in one of those long drive
contests
yeah you could probably make a very good
living traveling around
hustling and driving ranges a bartender
sets our martini in front of shooter
thanks phil that's that's you know i
know what you're doing right now
and i don't like it so why don't you
just shut your trap before i put my foot
in it
happy grabs the spear and turns back to
shooter shooter walks around in front of
happy
don't turn your back on me let's get one
thing straight this is shooter's tour
i've worked hard my whole life paid my
dues and now it's shooter's turn
and shooter's not about to let his reign
at the top be spoiled by some freak
sideshow clown did you just call me a
freak i was on this tour for one reason
money but now i got a new reason kicking
your ass
well ha ha i'd like to see you try happy
grabs his spear bottle and smashes it on
the bar
let's do it then i meant on a golf
course
off camera a woman yells and quickly
steps between shooter and happy to break
up the confrontation
hey hey what's going on here huh oh
i was just um looking for the other half
of this bottle and uh uh there's some of
it
there's some there's some right there
too why don't you just put it down yeah
i know
shooter walks away from the bar just
stay out of my way or you'll pay
listen to what i say how about i just go
eat some hay
i can make things out of clay and lay by
the bay i just may
what do you say
it's terrible this is terrible
aaron you really brought it man i tell
you what you saved the whole scene right
there
he did that's good aaron was great